- Hi, I'm Monica, the beauty expert.
Hi, I'm Ashley, the coordination maven.
[Monica] And today we're
gonna help one woman
avoid a quarter-life crisis.
(upbeat music)
Naomi, tell us about
your quarter-life crisis.
I am going to be a bridesmaid
in my best friend's wedding.
I have to find my bridesmaid's dress,
and then I have to get
ready to go to New York.
And then, I'm just a little nervous
'cause going to New York and being in
a very fancy wedding with
people I've never met before,
and they're like
beautiful, gorgeous women,
so I just feel very out of my element.
To start off, like,
before we even get into
all the stuff you have to do,
those beautiful, gorgeous women -
you are one of them also.
We'll get to give you tips and tools
to help you be in touch with that truth
and not forget it when you're there.
Thanks, guys. I'm excited!
Oh, you're so welcome.
Hi!
Okay, so here is where I get ready.
The one thing I'm really worried about
is I'm going straight from
the plane, my red eye,
straight to the all-day
bachelorette party.
Oh yes!
To start, for the skin-care stuff,
I think to make your
routine fast and easier,
I'm gonna recommend the Olay Total Effects
7 in One moisturizer.
It's gonna give you all the benefits
of all the stuff you have,
and it'll be one bottle,
so it's travel-friendly.
It's gonna give you the
same brightening effect,
combined with all the other stuff.
I have to have two major outfits:
the first one being
the bachelorette party,
which I hope you guys can help me
maybe find something in my closet
that I can wear;
and then the second one
being my bridesmaid's dress.
I'm thinking maybe this dress,
you can wear it in the day
and then just restyle it for night.
Maybe this for the night?
I mean, you can keep the
same dress on all day
but kinda revamp it.
I like it!
[Monica] Are you feeling this?
I am!
So, when I wake up, I turn off my alarm,
and then that just leads me
to checking all my social medias
and watching all these videos,
and then I start comparing
myself to other people,
and what they're doing,
and what I'm not doing,
and it just doesn't really set me up
to start my day positively.
One thing I wanna see happen is
we get you an alarm clock that
you can use instead,
and I want to help you
create a morning routine
that is gonna rock your world.
So, it's a couple of days in,
and I've been implementing
some of the things
that Ashley told me to do,
especially with social media.
She gave me this, which was so sweet.
This is where my phone goes at night
so I don't look at it,
especially when I wake up.
And then I feel like my
confidence is growing,
which makes me really
excited for the wedding,
'cause I feel like I'm gonna be
the best version of
myself when I get there.
So, I just cleansed my face,
so now it's time to try the Olay 7 in One
that Monica recommended.
Here she is.
Already it feels so good going on.
And then the bonus is it's travel size,
so I can just bring it
on the plane with me.
I was doing really well with, like,
not looking at my social
media in the morning,
and then it was like the weekend,
and I was like, "It's Saturday.
I don't have anything to do today.
I'll look at my phone in the morning,
and it'll be fine."
Like, you know when you do it
it's not gonna make you feel good.
It's not gonna make you feel like
the person you wanna be.
So, right now, I just
feel, like, disappointed.
So, tell us how it's been going
these last couple of weeks.
I think I've had some
really good things happen,
like with taking care of my skin
and using that moisturizer you suggested.
And then the other thing that
I checked off my list was
I officially nailed down a
bachelorette party outfit.
[Both] Yay!
But I am not doing very well with
the other two things
that you guys gave me.
I'm struggling with social media again,
and then because I've been looking,
I just can't get myself
to look up options for
my bridesmaid's dress.
Finding this dress might be
more fun than you think.
I just feel like sometimes
I have a block in my head
from going shopping with my mom
and never being able to, like,
find something that fits, you know?
So, I think that's a real
struggle that I'm dealing with.
Here, give me, give me your hand.
You're gonna find that dress,
and you're gonna feel so good.
You know what you're like,
and you're gonna find a dress.
Okay, thank you, guys.
(cheerful music)
Okay, so I have gotten
my dresses in the mail,
and I'm trying them on.
And this is the first one,
and I don't hate it!
I don't think this is the one.
I am having so much fun
trying all these dresses on.
All right, enough waiting.
Let's call her in.
Yeah, you're right, I can't wait anymore.
[Both] Naomi!
Hi!
[Ashley] You look amazing!
(shrieking)
You clearly killed this look.
This is a really good fit.
So, since you surprised us by
finally showing us this dress,
we have a surprise for you!
We have the bride, Melissa, on the line!
Oh, hi!
I think you look absolutely
stunning in this dress.
What I love about it is I feel like
it combines me and you into a dress,
'cause it's got the poof that's so you,
and then the lace is so me, and it just,
it's us together in a dress!
I love it!
I'm so glad I'm your friend
and that I get to be with you!
You're getting married!
Ladies, I just wanted to say,
thank you so much for
everything you've done for me.
Now I feel like a more
confident, beautiful,
radiant woman because of you two,
so thank you so much, ladies!
[Monica] You're so welcome!
Send us pictures!